Four years
ago, I was basically unemployed.
A wanderer with no home.
But now I'm a husband and a father,
and I wouldn't have it any other way.
And I'd pass my job
a little less just for renewal.
Oh, yeah.
I finally got a job.
and the King of Atlantis.
Half a billion people
from every known species in the sea
call this place home.
That is an email like me.
I'm going to kill off a man
and destroy everything he holds dear.
I'm going to murder his family
and burn his kingdom to as.
He must be stopped for a global
meltdown is imminent.
I think I know some.
I might build the helpless fool.
You look rough,
little brother, my friend.
Do not call me brother.
I cannot believe you let this happen.
Yeah, well, I need this job.
True.
King builds bridges, right?
True King builds bridges.
We need to find Manta.
He's different now.
He's stronger than before.
It's the Black Dragon
doing king at this time.
There were seven kingdoms
that try to force a curse upon them all.
Trying to start magic is spreading.
He means to end the bloodline.
I don't know what lies ahead,
but we can't leave our children in a world
without hope.
You know how his manager says
you think you,
if you lead,
the Seven Kingdoms, will follow?
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie, DC just
released a brand new Aquaman
2 trailer with way more footage,
so we'll break it all down.
the big thing in this trailer, obviously
being aqua baby like they're doing Aqua
Baby legit.
His name is Arthur Curry Juniors
all explain him in the movie itself
is more of a bromance between him and ORM
if your brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos.
There's a bunch of really big stuff
coming up.
I know there's lots of questions
about how this is going to fit
into the larger DC Universe
because technically it's a DCU movie
in James Guise,
rebooting everything into the DCU.
There were all those Batman Post-Credits
scenes like the Ben Affleck Batman
Post-Credits scene that they filmed
in the Michael Keaton Batman
Post-Credits scene that were both done
under different regimes, meant
to tie them to different future movies
that they had planned to do at the time.
James Wan, who did the movie, wouldn't
say anything about which Batman
was in the movie,
or if there were any Batman in the movie
at all,
He explained that the movie isn't meant
to be connected
to any of the preexisting movies
other than that first Aquaman movie.
we think that was him just saying
this Aquaman isn't meant to be the same.
Aquaman from the Flash Post-Credits scene.
meaning that they won't address
anything that happened in the Flash movie
during this movie,
which I think will be to its benefit,
largely
like it'll be relatively self-contained.
but I also think that that means
that probably will not be a Batman
post-credits scene anymore.
Maybe they'll just be like some funny
post-credits scene
referencing something from earlier
in the movie.
this trailer really is leaning heavily
on the Aquaman comedy of the first movie.
Basically
the same tone of the first movie.
Jason Momoa is basically
like the big dumb animal
or is like the straight man in their duo
throughout the movie.
Like he'll balance out all of his comedy
little brother, my friend.
Do not call me brother.
just reading
at the beginning of the trailer,
they do a custom logo amongst icebergs
because that's where they're going
to get to the Lost Kingdom.
the whole idea is that the Lost Kingdom
is like the seventh Kingdom of Atlantis.
During the trailer,
they feature a flashback
with King Atlan Fighting against
what looks like an undead king wielding
what they're calling the black trident
that black manta is using in present day.
this might be neck race.
He's actually being played by Pilou Abbas
from Game of Thrones.
He played the Euron Greyjoy character.
He's going to be every bit
as bad during this.
Too bad in a good way.
somehow it feels appropriate that Euron
Greyjoy is the main villain of this movie.
most of
the character though with special effects.
So I don't know if his face will be
visible underneath all that armor
During the trailer, their mother, Alana,
tells him that the dark magic of the Black
Triton is covering.
The rest of Atlantis
is going to consume the entire world.
I think the idea, just
based on all this green flame,
imbuing all these undead figures,
is that it's just bringing the dead
back to life.
the funny coincidence is
they're actually kind of doing something
similar on the Asoka series
in the Star Wars universe
with all the Knights sister zombie powers,
The Knight Sisters
use the similar type of green flame energy
that they literally call magic.
Dave Filoni probably didn't
plan things that way
because they've been working
on this alchemy
in two movie for a couple of years now.
But it just seems like Black Manta
gets himself a bunch of power upgrades
like during the trailer Alchemy
and says he's way more powerful
than he was last time not only does
he have a bunch of upgraded gear,
just regular human based technology,
It also seems like he's working with this
undead King Nicholas of the Lost Kingdom,
who gives him the black Triton,
which enables him to fight alchemy
with Atlantis.
Trident, The other big thing
too, in the trailer, obviously, he's
he says a couple of times that he's
going to kill Aquaman's entire family
and burn his entire kingdom.
Everything that he has,
burns his father's house down.
Don't know if he kills his father.
Also played by tomorrow, Morrison,
who is also in a lot of the Star Wars
stuff literally just had a cameo as Rex
during the last Asoka episode five.
but in the comics,
Black Manta is the person who winds up
killing Aquaman's son, Arthur
Curry Junior, also known as Aqua Baby.
don't know if they're going to roll
that hard in this movie.
Like I don't expect them to kill Orko baby
during this movie,
but obviously it's a really big thing in
the comics.
was one of the reasons
they caused him to break up with Meera,
like it
broke their marriage apart in the comics.
But basically Black Manta winds up
smothering his baby in the comics.
orca baby winds up
getting some of his powers
and some admirers powers
and some extra powers on top of that,
like he has the water bending powers.
That mirror has kind of like Avatar,
The Last Airbender, water bending.
They call them hard
water in the DC Universe.
he also temporarily gains
the power to create life
like he can create sea life
and manipulate its molecular structure.
So he is actually pretty powerful,
but he can't breathe on dry land.
The same with a lot of Highborn Atlanteans
can the probably changing
some of that stuff for the movie.
Because you see him on dry
land at Alchemy, his father's house
a lot of people wondering
about these shots.
Yes, they are from the first movie.
They reused some footage
from the first movie in the trailer.
But I think it's
just because of the flashback that he's
explaining the events of the first movie,
like I was employed for years ago.
And it shows some of the events
of the first movie
zoom in enhanced the dance
that Aquaman and his father are doing.
Actually scenes
like a traditional Maori dance, something
he was doing on the set of the Star Wars
Mandalorian Season two episodes
when he was filming Boba Fett stuff.
they make a couple of
jokes about what's happened in the year
that he's been king of Atlantis.
I think it's only been about a year
since the events of the first movie,
just charting the timeline of this.
there's a quick montage of him
stopping a bunch of disasters all around
Atlantis, like the chaos of all of these
half a billion people that he talks about.
The movie seems like it's going
to spend more time showing you
what's happening in and around Atlantis
with all these different people.
they kind of got into this
during the Black Panther
two movie with Namor
and their version of Atlantis in the MCU,
which was called Tallow Khan.
that was their way around of having
this weird copyright battle with DC.
They can't copyright the term Atlantis.
but they said when they were doing
the name war character in the MCU,
they didn't want people to immediately
think of Aquaman.
So they tried to make him feel
as different as possible
because he does seem a little bit
like Aquaman.
There's a big attack scene where Black
Manta comes in, attacks Atlantis
with all of his upgraded technology
and the Black Trident Galaxy,
all this green energy around it.
This seems like it's from the Lost City.
Looks like they're giving Nicole
Kidman way more action scenes in this.
She's going to be part of this big battle.
I don't know, the wind up killing her off
just feels like they want
to pay off black man to actually killing
some of Aquaman's family.
And they're probably not going to go as
hard as killing his son or killing Mira.
So I assume it's probably going to be
either his father or his mother.
They'll wind up sacrificing themselves
then because he can't fight them all
by himself.
He goes to free his brother arm
and it looks like his prison
is in the same place
where the kingdom of the deserters
was in that desert, the Sahara Desert,
from the last movie
The weird thing about this
is it actually seems like
he has to break him out of prison,
even though he's the king of Atlantis.
Like, technically
he is king of this former nation,
which seems like an undead place
now because of these undead guards.
look.
He has to wear his stealth suit to bust
into the prison and break his brother out.
they're couple of jokes about ORM getting
powerful again when he touches water.
That's the whole thing, is that
they're more powerful
in water than they are out of water.
that was why his prison was on dry
land in the driest place
you could possibly go in the desert.
Normally, he or like the other Highborn
Atlanteans are crazy
powerful in water,
some more powerful than others.
But when they're out of water,
they're just like a little bit stronger
than normal humans.
Like you've seen alchemy and fight
during the Justice League movies.
When he's not in water,
he's still very powerful.
But when they're in water, their power
levels go up by like a factor of ten.
Either funny thing you remember
is that that's exactly what name Wars
Powers were in the Marvel Universe.
Like, how do we defeat him
and get him out of the water, dry him out.
The couple jokes about alchemy,
just treating him like a brother and
or not wanting to have anything to do
with him, just wanting to save Atlantis
like they both want to save Atlantis,
But at least at first.
ORM still kind of hates Aquaman.
I think the idea is that their arc over
the movie is eventually they'll make peace
and ORM will like him.
They'll become friends
by the end of the film.
there's kind of a Thor Loki thing
going on between the two of them.
Two in the whole idea is that Aquaman
isn't that great at being king.
He doesn't want to be king,
kind of the way Thor was destined to be.
KING But it was always Loki
who wanted to be king so early theory.
Right now, Aquaman at the end of the movie
tries to abdicate the throne
or at least give the throne to ORM
and let him be king
because the whole idea is that
AUM knows what it means to be king.
He knows about ruling people.
He's much better
at that kind of stuff than a man would be.
you're to imagine
that all command is just way better
at being a member of the Justice League
fighting inter-dimensional villains,
kind of like dark side, for instance,
like really big, really bad cosmic
villains, managing large groups of people.
Though he's not so great at.
they have this whole Godzilla
Hollow Earth thing going on here.
This is meant to be the interior
of the Lost Kingdom.
I think this is inside
some sort of iceberg.
Either it's Antarctica
or somewhere in the Arctic.
Black Manta finds the lost kingdom.
These people actually seem
like they're working with him.
Like this is black mantas lair.
when.
ORM says he means to end the bloodline,
he's talking about black Manta
killing Aquaman in his entire family.
That's just a comic book reference to him
killing his son, basically
or and tries to give him a pep talk.
If you lead,
the Seven Kingdoms will follow.
So maybe Aquaman will end
the movie Still being King of Atlantis,
but it does seem like they will be bros
by the end of the film.
there's a whole bunch of stuff
going on in the trailer.
But if you spotted any Easter eggs
or references
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
And there's going to be tons of questions
about what Jason Momoa
is going to do in the future DC movies
because he said
he would always be Aquaman,
but he also said that he would be coming
back, possibly playing Lobo
I talked about this in my previous video.
I think he could do both.
Like it's a Thanos,
Josh Brolin and cable situation
where Kevin Foggy was like, Oh yeah,
he could come back in the Marvel movies
as cable after playing Thanos
just because they look so different.
His characters will see.
I don't think the Lobo character
is supposed to be in Superman legacy.
That would be like the big tipping point
where James Gunn's new DCU
really starts to set off.
there'll be other DCU projects
that happened before that.
But I'll just do videos
about all that stuff
when we get new trailers
for everything else
there were a couple of the trailers
and also just released.
I try to do videos for everything
as soon as possible,
so be sure to enable alerts
for my channels. You don't miss that.
click here for my Ahsoka Episode
6 video and click here for my new Batman
to Robin video because it looks like we're
going to get Robin in the Batman too.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!